the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a trailer breakdown video The Game of
Thrones gods have blessed us because HBO
just uploaded several different official
trailers on their YouTube channel I
actually wasn't expecting to be making
another video so soon but now that these
trailers have official releases I could
not resist now we have already seen some
of these images before but there is also
some new footage in here as well let's
start off by talking about the first
video which is titled together this one
starts off by showing some of the
footage we have already seen here we can
see Jon and Daenerys as they are
arriving together in Winterfell as the
trailer begins we can hear Tyrion
Lannister givin a little speech tyrion
says we must fight together now or we
will die that scene appears to be taking
place inside of the main dining hall in
Winterfell right over Tyrion shoulder we
can see Sansa Stark and Daenerys
Targaryen and there is also a very good
chance that Jon Snow could be sitting
right in the middle of them but Tyrion
is blocking the view this could be
shortly after John and Danny arrive or
this could be right after Jaime arrives
as we all know most of the northerners
do not like Targaryen especially one
that has a foreign army marching behind
her nor do they like the Lannisters they
are not gonna be happy when Jon shows up
and allow all these outsiders right into
their backyard I'm sure that summer John
and Songz's bannermen have already
expressed how they feel which may lead
to Tyrion given that speech now they
might not like the Targaryen Zoar the
Lannisters but they will have to admit
that Tyrion is right in order for all of
them to have a chance against the night
king they will have to stick together or
else they will die just like Tyrion said
in the scene so I'm thinking Tyrion is
saying this to try to get everyone else
in the room to calm down because I'm
sure the tension in the room is very
high now this next scene is also
something we saw in the first trailer
this also looks to be like the arrival
at Jon Snow and Daenerys in the first
episode the next scene is also
from the first trailer here we can see
three different Greyjoy ships at first
glance this might seem like it's you're
on Greyjoy escorting the golden company
back to King's Landing but that could
also be Theon Greyjoy and maybe even his
sister
these ships do not look like they are
transporting hundreds or thousands of
men so there is a very good chance that
this is actually Theon and not you're on
in the next scene we can see the Dragons
once again now it's hard to say exactly
where they're at but it's most likely
somewhere in the far north
now some fans have said this could
actually be John and Daenerys taking the
dragons for a ride which might be
accurate HBO might have done some CGI
work to make it look like no one is
riding on the Dragons backs that way it
doesn't ruin the surprise in the trailer
now there doesn't look like there are
any roads for all the men to travel so I
highly doubt this is from the same
opening scene where John and Danny
arrived in Winterfell my guess is this
is later in the season this could be
right around the same time we see John
and Danny walking up to the Dragons out
in the middle of nowhere I don't see any
other men or horses in that scene either
so this is most likely from a scene
where we get to see Jon write a dragon
now this next scene looks like it could
be very interesting we can see Jon and
Daenerys most likely inside of the
Starks castle Dany has her back turned
to Jon so I'm betting there is some
tension in this scene as well Jon might
have said something to Dany or Danny
might have said something to Jon but
either way it has made Daenerys turn her
back to Jon we see Jon begin to exit the
room and it doesn't look like Danny
turns around so she is probably upset
about something it could have something
to do what Jon's claim to the Iron
Throne or maybe even their baby it's
hard to say when there is no dialogue
but I just have a feeling Danny did not
like whatever Jon told her next we can
see Sansa getting a good look at the
dragons again and there really isn't
anything new that I can add to this so
let's just move on to the next one
now here we can see beric Dondarrion
once again but this time he's fighting
in what I think is the great battle
against the night King and Winterfell we
can see that beric Dondarrion has his
sword lit on fire and it looks like this
is from the same scene where we see the
Hound and the trailer that actually
looks like the hounds face right in
front of the camera now this is just a
guess but since there is fire everywhere
I would bet that the Hound has stopped
fighting we
you always see him freeze up whenever
there is fire and it looks like Barrack
might actually save him from getting
killed we saw the same thing happen when
the Hound went out beyond the wall he
was nearly killed by the bear because he
had frozen up once again eventually the
Hound will have to get over his fear of
fire because they could end up getting
him killed
just like in this scene this really is
an interesting turn of events because
back in season 3 beric Dondarrion and
the Hound were fighting each other to
the death but now it looks like Barrack
might actually save his life in the next
scene we can see Daenerys Targaryen
standing in the courtyard of Winterfell
it looks like someone just gave her some
bad news because she is about to start
to cry I'm thinking she just found out
the night king resurrected her dragon
Vasari on it was already bad enough when
Danny had to watch her dragon die but
knowing the night king brought him back
to life just to use against you must be
like getting kicked right in the teeth
this is the look from someone that knows
they might have to eventually kill their
own dragon which I do believe Danny will
have to do with the help from dragon in
the next scene we can see Jon Snow
fighting someone or something this is
also most likely from the Battle of
Winterfell and he's probably killing
either a white or a white Walker next we
can see Cersei Lannister standing alone
but she does turn around very quickly my
guess is someone just entered the room
and it looks like she turns around
dramatically so this is probably during
a big scene we do know that John and
Daenerys have to fight Cersei at some
times so maybe this is when Cersei knows
they're making it inside the castle or
even inside that very room this next
scene is a little interesting as well
here we can see Varys Davos and Tyrion
all of them are looking up into the sky
most likely at one of the dragons but
why are they looking at it like that
they have all seen dragons quite a few
times already I don't think they're
looking at the night King and his dragon
because you can see that it is daytime
and we know the night king army arrives
at night could this be when Jon Snow and
Danny are riding the dragons together
that would be my guess
they have seen dragons before but they
have never seen Jon write a dragon or
anyone else besides Dany ride a dragon
alone so that would certainly get their
attention okay now this next scene is
something I've been wanting to talk
about we did see this in the first
trailer already and I think most fans
think this is when everyone is
running back inside of the castle
because they show John running then they
immediately show other characters
running back inside of the gates however
I do not think this is from the same
scene look at everything around John
Snow
there aren't any other characters around
him we can also see that there are fires
in several different areas so this is
most likely late into the battle I think
John is either charging at the night
King or he is running to save someone's
life the way they filmed this scene
makes me think it's very dramatic
we can see that John Snow is centered in
the frame running straight down the
barrel of the camera I just had this
feeling this could be when John
challenges the night came we know John
isn't afraid to run right into the
battle by himself and if he sees an
opportunity to take the night King out
I'm betting he will take advantage of
that next we get a nice shot of the
unsullied and it looks like they're
trying to stop a large force from
getting any closer they are standing
shoulder to shoulder with all their
weapons sticking out in front of them
they could be trying to stop a large
group of whites from getting inside of
the castle then once again we can see
Arya Stark slicing and dicing the enemy
it looks like she is on top of the
battlements of Winterfell so this
probably means everyone had to fall back
to the castle and now the knight king's
army is making it over the walls you can
see there must be a large fire in the
back so things are not looking good for
House Stark at this moment this has to
be right before Arya gets chased through
the castle then of course we get the
great shot of the knight king's army
arriving at Winterfell with the Stark
Castle right ahead
and we also get to seen where we can see
the dragon getting ready to catch
someone or something on fire what's
interesting about this is it almost
appears as if the dragon is inside
somewhere but there aren't too many
places these damn dragons could fit I'm
starting to wonder if this could be
inside of the Red Keep and King's
Landing
the dragon could certainly fit inside of
there once the roof is missing I wonder
if this is the dragon melting down the
Iron Throne HBO did release the official
image for season a and we can see that
it is the Iron Throne as well as a
dragon now obviously these have been the
two biggest symbols of power in the
series but I have always had a feeling
that the Iron Throne would get melted
down now I guess you could say the
dragon could be killing someone in that
scene but I think it's something else
now the second trailer HBO uploaded
today is called survival this one starts
off with Jon Snow standing out at
Winterfell as gods would only this time
we can see Arya Stark is standing right
behind him now this is the reunion I
have been waiting for ever since the
first season I think they have already
reunited before this scene but you know
what I mean just like I said in my first
breakdown video I think John went out
here to reflect on everything that he
has been told
Arya may be coming out here to reassure
John that she still thinks of him as a
brother or something along those lines
I'm sure it will be one of those
heartfelt scenes next we just see an
establishing shot of King's Landing
followed up by Cersei and Qyburn
it looks like Cersei is happy about
something whereas Qyburn looks a little
worried he must not agree with whatever
is about to happen but it's really hard
to say then we see another scene from
the first trailer but this time we can
see Jorah Mormont is walking into the
room where Daenerys is at that could be
from the same scene where we saw
Daenerys having our back turn to John it
did look like John was getting ready to
leave the room so maybe Jorah walks in
right after John walks out like I said
before Danny does not look very happy
I'm guessing she found out her and John
are related or John has a better claim
to the Iron Throne or it could even be
about their baby or Vasari on like I
said she does not look very happy so
maybe Jorah is coming in to try to
comfort Dany then we get a nice shot of
the Starks castle with the dragons
flying right overhead we can see that a
good bit of the men have set up camp
right behind the castle this could be
from the same scene where Sansa gets a
good look at the dragons then we go down
into the crypts of Winterfell and John
is standing right next to Ned Stark's
statue it doesn't look like John is
wearing the big fur coat so I don't
think this is from the same scene from
the first trailer where we saw Daenerys
standing next to John he most likely
came down here for the same reasons he
went out to the weirwood tree now the
rest of the scenes are pretty much all
from the first trailer there isn't
really much more I can say that I
haven't already said in other videos now
I want to move on to the new video HBO
just released today it looks like this
video highlights the aftermath of the
Battle for Winterfell
they have focused so much other trailers
on the Starks home and a battle for
Winterfell I think this is where the
battle will end
I know there have been some thoughts
that maybe the Starks will have to
abandon their castle but I don't know
about that I still think the battle will
end here this is where winter will fall
now the new video starts off with the
Starks banner flapping in the wind the
castle appears to be completely empty at
the time I don't even think we saw any
dead bodies lying in the snow
we do however start to see some remnants
of the battle we can see there are some
dragon class arrows which we all knew
there would be then we see Tyrion
Lannister's hand to the Queen pin then I
can see what looks to be Arya Starks or
needle the one that Jon gave her all the
way back in the first season after that
it looks like they show us the feather
from the crypts of Winterfell most
likely the same one from Leona statue
then we see the feather fall down to the
ground and at the bottom of the steps it
looks like bran Starks wheelchair has
been broken almost as if bran was thrown
down the steps then we see Jaime
Lannister's golden hand and right next
to that as Daenerys Targaryen chained
the one that had the three-headed dragon
on it and last but not least we see Jon
Snow Valyrian steel sword long claw
lying in the snow it looks like his
sword is covered in blood now if you
look right behind the sword it looks
like someone or something is walking
right through the archway now who could
that be is that a white a white Walker
or the knight came by the looks of the
trailer it appears as if everyone is
dead there isn't a single character to
be seen other than the shadowy figure
walking behind Longclaw so what the hell
does all of this mean could we really
lose all of our beloved characters at
the Battle for Winterfell I don't think
so we will absolutely lose some of the
main characters but there is no way that
all of them died in that battle I think
this just really represents all the
death and destruction that will take
place during the battle the Starks
Castle will absolutely be destroyed
along with most of the men and woman
fighting in the battle but we still have
Cersei Lannister to deal with there is
no way that all of our main characters
die before they get a chance to face off
against Cersei and you're on greyjoy in
King's Landing this will probably be the
last trailer we get so I'm betting they
just wanted to hype up this season one
more time by show
some really creepy visuals let me know
what you think about all the new images
HBO has been releasing I'm sorry to cut
the video short but I have to get back
to work I am currently in the process
I'm moving to another state and I still
have so much to do before my furniture
gets here tomorrow I was very happy that
HBO did release some new trailers but it
couldn't have happened at a worse time
for me if you could actually see the
room that I'm recording in right now you
would probably be surprised that I'm
even able to make this video right now
there is stuff stacked up all over the
entire room it's really a complete mess
as soon as I get finished moving in I
will be making some other videos about
the new trailers so thank you all for
your patience anyways I really
appreciate everyone stopping by to watch
the video thank you very much and I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you